we begin this morning with the
continuing fallout from President
Trump's decision to withdraw from the
Paris climate agreement since the
announcement Thursday some aides to the
president have defended his decision
while others have ducked questions about
whether he believes in climate change
after he previously called it a hoax now
an increasing number of state leaders
say climate change is very real on
Friday the governors of Massachusetts
Vermont Connecticut and Rhode Island
announced they would be joining
California Washington and New York in
forming the u.s. climate alliance a
collection of states committed to
meeting the standards of the Paris
climate agreement Paula Reid is at the
White House Paula good morning good
morning and we know this president is no
stranger to controversy but this
decision to withdraw from the Paris
Accords drew international outcry and on
Friday White House officials spent most
of the day defending their boss against
the world the president made a very
courageous decision yesterday in behalf
of America EPA chief Scott Pruett a
leading voice in convincing President
Trump to get out of the Paris climate
Accord defended his boss Friday against
critics we have nothing to be apologetic
about as a country vice president Mike
Pence also came to the president's
defense for making good on a campaign
promise we're putting the American
worker the American economy first but
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson who was
opposed to leaving the Paris Accord
downplayed the president's decision
on Friday a number of administration
officials wouldn't give direct answers
when asked if the President believes
climate change is a hoax as he said at
rallies during the campaign a lot of
it's a hoax it's a hoax yes or no does
the president believe that climate
change is real and a threat to the
United you know what's interesting about
all the discussions we had through the
last several weeks have been focused on
one singular issue is Paris good or not
for this country what does the president
actually believe what kind of climate
change does he still believe it's a hoax
um you clarify that apparently nobody
else in the White House okay yeah I have
not had an opportunity to have that
discussion in Europe the president's
move was met with shock and dismay
German Chancellor Angela Merkel was
defiant thus divided this decision
cannot and will not deter all of us who
feel obliged to protect this earth she
said under the Paris agreement the
United States had the authority to
reduce u.s. greenhouse gas emission
targets to make them less onerous on
American businesses press secretary Sean
Spicer said that wasn't good enough the
President believes that it is in a car
country's best interest to to
renegotiate the deal European leaders
also made it clear they had no intention
of renegotiating instead less than 24
hours after the US withdrawal European
leaders welcomed China's Premier Li cun
chang and vowed to create new green jobs
to fight global warming on Thursday
Frances president Emmanuel macron called
on the world in English to make the
planet great again while many world
leaders were criticizing President
Trump's decision Russia's leader
Vladimir Putin says he won't judge he
also noted that the agreement doesn't
actually go into effect until 2021
giving leaders plenty of time to
negotiate an alternative solution
Alex Paula Reid at the White House
thanks Paula